das ist mein deutsch und das ist mein
waschzeug mit ihm möchte ich unsere
tägliche kleinen wäsche in kaum fünf
minuten in unserem leben sehen wir sie
endlose male jeden tag auf einer
bushaltestelle im fernsehen oder auf
unserem handy werbung und in den
allermeisten fällen sind ehrlich
miteinander leute ist werbung etwas was
man nicht unbedingt gerne sieht sondern
über sich ergehen lässt aber es gibt
auch einige seltene besondere fälle in
denen man sich werbung gerne ansieht
zum beispiel wenn die werbung 40 jahre
alt und mittlerweile absolut lächerlich
ist ich habe nämlich von einer
zuschauerin namens wiki merkt den tipp
bekommen dass ich mal auf alte werbung
reagieren sollte passend dazu hat sie
mir video mit geschickt das heißt
witzige werbung aus 70er und 80er jahren
und miss da rein und gucken was unseren
eltern erzählt wurde damit die produkte
kaufen
meine güte jetzt kommt besuch schnee weg
mit dem pack rühmen
wer sich mit dem staub saugen anfangen
die nicht mit dem leid schon fertig
jeder kennt die situation leute man hat
gleich besucher es klingelt dann ruft
man laut meine güte
jetzt kommt der besucher erleben und
dann hat man einfach an so einem
tischbein aber so zwei gezielte häuschen
an krümeln einfach der komplette
teppiche sonst sauber für zwischendurch
den leifheit und die krümel sind weg der
besuch reinkommt leifheit container für
zwischendurch schon mal was vom
staubsauger gehört wofür brauche ich
dann eine kehrmaschine kann es werde
erklären warum ich den verkehr maschine
braucht ein staubsauger hat so
marketingabteilung von unternehmen sind
genial
ok also fast jeder haushalt in
deutschland hat ein staubsauger um dreck
wegzumachen übrigen die kehrmaschine auf
den markt die nicht mal elektrisch ist
genial sie können ihre zähne putzen wie
sie wollen in zahnzwischenräume kommt
ihre zahnbürste nicht was bleibt zehn
speisereste das ist der lohn träger
dieser gesicht sonst was da passiert hat
der kameramann seine hose ausgezogen
ich habe manchmal so ein gesicht wenn
man realisiert dass minimale essensreste
zwischen den zehen bleiben nach dem
zähneputzen
deshalb gibt es jetzt die munddusche
brocks alter was ist das für eine alien
technologie dieser frage sieht aus wie
so ein wasserkocher und dann kommt so
ein kabel nicht mehr die sache ist das
ding hat wahrscheinlich sogar noch 300
mark gekostet was schief anschaut dass
man einfach zahnseide benutzt nein
verzichten sie jetzt auf zahlreiche und
kaufen sie unsere überteuert der
e-ink-technologie zahnärzte bestätigen
brockstedt verbessert ihre
zahngesundheit zahnärzte bestätigen
brokser jet ist kein von menschenhand
geschaffenes produkt dieses produkt
stammt von den paletten gamma centauri
der nach heutigem kenntnisstand von 5
bei dingen aliens bewohnt ist die sind
die torsten cloos bringt frisch ist ein
minder abend toll und getestetes
graubrot und frisch ist einen abend toll
und getestetes graubrot ja immer klar
70er 80er menschen das ist ein fucking
toaster okay das brot ist knusprig ja
gut
tolle mutter die nachbarn haben
fließendes wasser welche wunder sagen
wir erfindung ist dies ja mein siemens
automatik thorsten mit seinen vielen
extras ist es ist einfach toll welche
welche vielen extras hat dieser toaster
er ist einfach schwarz dann in so einem
ganztägigen brown noch eine scheibe
drauf die sonnenblumen
der schmalste toaster den es gibt das
geschenk mit dem gewissen extra könnt
euch das vorstellen was für eine welt
das war in der es krass waren tost dazu
haben wir damals wie heute sind
ausgerastet diesen fast gekommen
unterhielt das ihr brot knusprig ist
schon mal vor man hätte einfach so einem
menschen aus dem zeitalter also
zeitalter gutes war vor 40 jahren man
hätte so der person einfach das internet
gezeigt die waren geplatzt das ist mein
und das ist mein waspo mit ihm möchte
ich unsere tägliche kleinen wäsche in
kaum fünf minuten da gibt es keine
planschen ein waschbecken aus welchem
jahr tausende ist diese werbung es geht
schneller und billiger als mit der
waschmaschine
der waschbär von kana ist die ideale
ergänzung zu unserer waschmaschine carlo
war sport
es ist genau das gleiche wie dieses
leifheit wie diese kehrmaschine warum
die leute haben schon staubsauger und
sie haben schon eine waschmaschine sind
ist die erfindung der siebziger und
achtziger jahre so hey wir wissen er hat
schon ein produkt was die sache die sie
machen wollt wirklich gut macht und wir
haben uns dann gedacht wir bringen noch
ein produkt auf dem markt was genau das
gleiche macht nur halt nicht ganz so gut
wie das was sie schon habt bitte kauft
es moulinex dosenöffner sony nex
dosenöffner der modi next dosenöffner
öffnet alle diese elektrischen alter
kommen auch einen markennamen gleis okay
wir wissen es ist ein dosenöffner okay
und wir wissen dass euer unternehmen
moulinex heißt scheinbar ihr müsst es
sich innerhalb der ersten sekunde drei
mal sagen und dem hintergrund sind also
irgendwie okay sonst verstanden wir
haben erst verstanden der laden heißt
budimex ok spielt jetzt mal ein
messerscharfer
er ist ein messer schneidet sie stücke
das würde ich mir kaufen also rät auch
so dosenöffner der automatisch
funktioniert das ist wirklich ein geiles
produkte sind da hab ich mir schon
besser ist die kehrmaschine die kinder
das gleiche mache den staubsauger hat
nicht ganz so gut wie topf sollte das
wirklich verkaufen will das geil alter
mann dann kann ich meine diversen selbe
schärfen und mir werden dass eine dose
öffnen lassen
wir können gleich ok hab mir mal worum
es hierbei geht ich glaube und das ist
allgemein so das ding ist in der phase
war mega viel werbung so für hausfrauen
wahrscheinlich ist es jetzt irgendwie
schnell koffer selbst gemacht sein
leibgericht dosen frau half es kennt das
so althammer verdammte scheiße ich muss
jeden tag in die schule
ok ich muss mich konzentrieren ich muss
zum sport kann ich nicht mal gescheite
nahrung bekommt was soll dieser dosen
fraß und warum lässt du die ganzen
werbeslogans von müllers müde vor
schwimmer töpfe man schmeckt die
sorgfalt von müller's mühle noch mal an
der stelle liebe menschen aus den 70ern
und 80ern
es ist einfach dosen fraß okay ich weiß
es verwirrend das essen fertig aus der
dose kommen kann aber kein gut
auszulasten und magie hat eine neue idee
wie man hackfleisch anders zubereiten
kann halt obacht verdammte scheiße man
booker wer diese stimme herrmann
ich bin da lag ich in meiner küche
westlich der raum ist leer und warum es
spielt mein idol mitten in der luft
können bitte weitermachen ich will
einfach dass dieses amt vorschlagen
mache
ich will es machen halt magie hat eine
neue idee wie man hackfleisch anders
zubereiten kann
in dieser packung ist alles um 200 gramm
hackfleisch in deftig delikaten noodles
tragen auf zu verwandeln also nochmal
fertignahrung das muss ein großes ding
gewesen sein aber es in den 70ern feine
eier nudeln und eine ernsthafte saucen
mischung aus champignons sahne zwiebeln
und vielen guten gewürzen das ist die
idee wie man fleisch anders zubereiten
kann nur instructor es ist einfach
fertignahrung ok gewissen finde ich
alles hört auf und erholen dass sie
einfach fertig name anbietet so alle
fertig namens anbieter aus den 70er und
80er sowie krebs geheilt so stelle ich
mir die 70er 80er vor so diese musik
spielt menschen in so ritter menschen in
ritterrüstungen und so alten weiten
kleidern springen über so eine wiese und
tanzen so dazu bei dass unser die 70er
meiner vorstellung wenn ein geschenk mit
so viel liebe gemacht ist weiß der
beschenkte ohne viel worte wie gern man
ihn hat
selbe sache ist sind süßigkeiten ist
einfach eine süßigkeit mit viel zucker
vielen ungesunden fetten ganz ehrlich
ich habe mich mehr von mir irgendjemand
kanada ein steak schenkt diese kleine
überaus ungesunde diabetes und carius
fördernde portion nahrung als zeichen
dafür dass das ich dich gerne aber
kaffee zigaretten liegt kann ich auch
liebe frau mit seltsamen topfschnitt was
ist das für ein einkauf alter willst du
die leute vergiftet kaffee kaffee ist
okay aber ist einen mengen
wahrscheinlich auch nicht so gut
zigaretten schnaps gebäck also plätzchen
süßigkeiten
was fehlt dann noch für den kompletten
einkauf um eine familie gesund zu
ernähren also der kleine martin krieg
schon mal seine zigaretten die kann
damit seinen fünf jahren auch gut
vertragen papa hat seinen schnaps wir
haben auch viele zuckerhaltige
fetthaltige lebensmittel damit ich schön
fett werden nicht unbedingt die klügste
entscheidung was für eine zeit leute
hören sie über toaster und fertignahrung
noch richtig gefreut hat und der familie
einkauf einfach aus kippen schnaps und
süßigkeitenstand wir haben diese
menschen überlebt das gilt es noch zu
klären leute was aber jetzt schon
geklärt ist ist dass es hier drüben
einen für euch persönlich vorgeschlagen
das video gibt und dass ich für euch
gerne einen zweiten teil machen denn wir
haben bisher nur drei minuten 20 von
zehn minuten 32 von diesem video gesehen
also wenn ihr zweiter teil am gold
kommentierte vielleicht hat dieses video
zeigt das video drüben ab und bis zum
nächsten mal
macht's gut